What is happening?
Are we waiting for this truck to unload?
Who taught you how to drive?
You stupid motherfucker!
-I'm begging you not to...
-Hey, don't talk to my husband like that.
You come over here
and you say that to my face!
Don't come over here.
-Fuck you!
-Fuck you! Fuck you back, you moron!
-Honey, you got him.
-What's going on with you?
-I'm just anxious to see everybody.
What? With our friends?
Last week we were adults
before we moved here and turned 19 again.
It's a reunion! The friend group is back!
I know you love your college friends,
but every time you get together with them
you all become a bunch of little bitches.
-You remember Felix, my partner?
-Hi.
So loud.
We've got like 20 years
of grievances built up.
It gets so competitive.
Hey!
You don't have to grunt
everytime you hit the ball!
I don't even hear myself,
I'm just so kinda...
Really?
It sounds like you're taking a shit.
I've been here ten minutes,
you've taken 3,000 shits.
No, that's not what it sounds like
when I poop.
I love my life.
I just wonder what would happen
if it was blown to smitherines
and I got to start all over again.
So it has nothing to do with your affair?
It was a stupid college hook-up
that never ended.
Why do you insist on calling it an affair?
Because you're married to other people
and having sex with each other.
This job. They're evil.
Fucking cocksucker!
So you went to Harvard?
Yeah.
-I went to Princeton.
-Right.
How do you sleep with women
that are half your age?
It's soul crushing!
We're good people.
This party's gonna be off the hook!
Oh, my God! Oh, sir.
-We are such bad people.
-Such bad people.
-Do you want to have a child?
-I don't know!
You're the type of person
that has to have meaning in their life.
There's two things
that matter in this world,
nipples and butts.
And he's got all three.
I want everyone to know that
after a long talk with Max last night,
I have decided to go ahead
and try to like you.
That is achievable!
What are you guys doing?
-Slo-mo.
-Just doing slow motion.
-Slo-mo, it's really cool.
-Blink slow.